yeah she stopped working apartment so
thank you for our next Gordon Potkin
he's going to continue this talking
about compositional compositionality
adequacy and fullest fraction from an
algebraic point of view
ya know physics as I know none so thank
you very much the organizers for the
invitation and curiously enough I had
been thinking about this anyway so he
fit it in so he's a little kind of
personal Odyssey thing terms of three
questions so many years ago came across
a paper we said that given any semantic
so watch the semantics you've got a
language some bunch of meaning so you
just got a function for the language the
bunch of meetings that's it nothing
special just a function or a morphism in
some category and it doesn't need to be
compositional can it be made
compositional any ways that are natural
canonical for a compositional semantics
you can associate with it this paper
showed how to produce such a semantic is
very nice they couldn't find the
reference I started reconstructing it
and then I came across this paper by
Wilfred Hodges 2001 and he in fact has
the the construction of the theorem
there and it's very nice but what you do
is to me compositional T as a where
automatically takes care of context and
so his semantics involves a function
from context I think I like that very
much because is when you do these
various examples like for example in the
state there was a kind of a context or a
Montague semantics of natural language
there's always bringing in context
bringing in enough context you can make
things compositional so this theorem
seemed like a way of doing that but when
you look to see what this canonical
semantics was in fact it is a chronicle
fully abstract semantics
well because our semantics what's
difference between semantics with Jamie
and operational semantics the answer is
nothing you just the same
meaning for meaning you're right be for
behavior and instead of em for meaning
set of meanings you write beef the set
of behaviors right now this level of
abstraction anyhow there's no no
difference whatever and so if you read
these these as behaviors then the
construction here is the construction
the canonical fully abstract semantics
and that and that's a possibly a nice
place for us to go because for example
I'll try this with differential
equations you've existence theorems now
actually finding solutions
so it couldn't be something similar in
computer science we have general
constructions that for the abstract
models but then of course in particular
cases to really see it it's a huge
amount of work but are they're cheap are
they're cheap theorems so this is
basically all about a single cheap
theorem you're laughing you don't get
very much you don't get ready cheap
chips are one one one step up from films
from people not much anyhow turned out
this has all been done before by shoe
Cimber she thanked me kill I explained
this to me when I came here I told him
we found it
she wasn't buried 965 has the syntactic
monoid later on that was generalized to
arbitrary alter brothers I don't know
who by but he's an early reference Stein
beer 1992 so here the idea is you still
have a language like shusun birthdays l
would be the set of all strings okay and
you have a coloring and that's just a
function from C then matters MBR C to to
see the set of colors so for example the
colors could be like boolean 0 or 1 and
you go to one if you're in this language
or undo if you're not so the question is
can you factor this through a natural
algebra is the syntactic one right and
then you care about relationship between
the nature of the language the nature of
the monoblock that's where the theory
type
a number of small steps whereas the more
abstract semantics gross things other
kinds of ways sometimes very hard to
model those in the more abstract ways so
I think there are distinctions I didn't
say there weren't distinctions to me I
kept resting at this very abstract level
well Scoob it's only going to be cheap
theorems you won't get much for my money
let's get something really let's do a
quick review of compositionality which
occurs everywhere in languages do to
Frager people say the meaning of a
linguistic phrase determined by many of
his parts so in arithmetic the meaning
of one plus three plus five has got two
parts one plus three and five and you
know what their meanings are find them
out add them up you're done programming
languages ask where's per thanks Prakash
so you know we know that one already I
don't need to go through again logic the
meaning of a conjunction is is fine for
the meaning of his conjunct that they
are both true false or conjunctions
false and natural language Jack like
Jill is determined by the meaning of
Jack and the meaning of Jill perhaps no
no that knows the point I didn't see
plus and I didn't see semicolon I didn't
see and where the parts are no didn't
see likes for a part so the point here
is what is composition our teachers our
language of the compositional semantics
is not a fully determined question
it needs a notion of analyzing syntax in
two parts and I've chosen one idea there
you chose and other ideas and I don't
want to choose between the ideas they
want to point out that's like in a
parameter and what's more it may be the
case that you should do a syntactic
transformation the meaning of a phrase
isn't going to be given by directly but
only via a translation Center deep sea
from surface and title deep cement
deeper syntax so there's a lot to just
answering the question does natural
language or on the other language of a
compositional semantics it really
requires a good theory of syntax another
point what to make here there's a
jack-and-jill are objects and Jack likes
Dilla's our proposition and here
zero and one objects so there can be
different types which is what Prakash
always pointed out but what I'm going to
do for the most part the first part of
this talk I'll do a single sorted thing
and the multi sorts of things that
immediate it's just very simple version
of the same thing not just do that in a
slide but so let's just do one sort to
get to keep things simple
you really have L sub s for s a set of
source or types or something okay so we
need some model of syntax so what people
just take is there is the initial
algebra you just have an algebraic
signature and you just take all terms
over the signature so so so we'll take L
to work our signature collection to find
operation symbols all play each of our
TN and we have the set of close terms
it's just the kind of thing at Prakash
hide up there but slightly more abstract
so if t1 to TN or term shows up of t1
through TN of course they sell be empty
unless you have some operation simple
parity 0 but you will have those
so-called constants and compositionality
at this level says the meaning of opt of
t1 to TN this OP could be like surplus
or whatever a it's just eaten by the
meaning of t1 through TN another
principle linguistic principles
sometimes people talk about endorse
write world it's saw substitute if 'ti
this is an equivalent principle is sort
of saying the same thing slightly
differently a if t1 let's define an
equivalence relation T and u are um
equivalent if they have the same if M of
T equals M of you so we're given any
function going to get an equivalence
relation and correspondingly given any
equivalence relation or get function
mapping to the to the equivalence
classes yeah we say if T if the T's are
equivalent then the ops are equivalent
class another way of seeing it and
that's defined there okay
so ultimately you recognize what's going
on we've got congresses coming up and or
or more morphisms coming up but we let's
kind of spell all that out so maybe this
is Slater height so a Sigma algebra set
and maps a set for the sort single sort
and maps reach the operation symbols or
morphisms from one ta let us preserve
everything those initial artery but
initial algebra is the set of linguistic
phrases according to previous slides
analysis was said to linguistic phrases
is
and so that's just L Sigma the eye
operation applied to T's is OP apply to
the t's it's just a syntactic the
syntactic thing and the point is for any
other ultra brothers unique hala
morphism from I to be as all no and so
each of the offices they be off of the
ATS of the t's so this is all standard
stuff so the question is
compositionality and homomorphism feel
like the same thing but let's just as it
were spell it out but not quite the same
thing but they're almost the same thing
hey so given a homomorphism that's
certainly that's a map from I to M it's
certainly compositional because each of
the offices off of H is so the meaning
of the whole is determined by the
meanings of the part so that way around
it's pretty obvious but what about the
other way around well any compositional
semantics here is here can actually be
factored as a homomorphism followed by
an inclusion but the natural algebra to
me seems not to be an algebra M but now
to brown the image of the semantics so
the mean the set of meanings of L cause
you talked about the meaning of the
whole determined by the meaning of the
part
so what take are to be the the image of
L Sigma under M subset of M and the
operation on the meanings of the parts
will be the meaning of the whole okay
now so that defines operations there I
mean you could define an algebra near so
what they are what you would do there if
there's some arguments which weren't the
denotation of anything you just give
something arbitrary that doesn't sound
very nice so this OP is not defined all
of them all DNR but you could define up
and all them just by making an arbitrary
definition if you wanted but it doesn't
seem right somehow so yeah you can go
really if you want to do part for bra
that's a well-known jungle
anyhow I think this this seems to me he
said since I've got charged the right
way to do it
hey okay no I will say whoa I didn't see
how Congress is but we all know what
Congress is they're given an equivalence
relation respecting the operations the
congruence in algebra when you take this
the collection of equivalence classes
and the operations work on the
equivalence classes natural waste and
you've got an average in hormone
morphism that's something everyone I
suppose
knows a as I said before
substitutability is just that this
relation is a congress initial algebra
and how if you do that you could use the
previous thing and you get another
factorization this is kind of a dual
factorization the previous one instead
of looking at a bit of m and doing
another one we just take L think when we
divide out by the congruence of having
the same meaning a so but this
factorization is actually equivalent the
previous factorization and some suitable
notion of equivalence that's just two
different points of view a okay so
that's got a quick review of our
compositionality and substitutive ax t
and so forth and so what I want to do is
begin to work my way towards Wilfred's a
construction but in so doing we can look
at what things like advocacy and
compositionality mean everyone knows
what they mean roughly the point is we
can make precise definitions here and
there are even basically categorical
definitions if one was to write
generally so I think so that's so that's
nice so so so homomorphic semantics here
is here is adequate prod at the
notational semantics if this guy
determines that guy normally a sentence
here if I know it's H meaning that I
know it's admitting but that tells me
there's a function from here to here so
we can simply say that as semantics here
is adequate for this given one if this
one factors through it
that's adequacy now I've talked about
full abstraction we have talked about
context the context are just terms with
a hole in it one or more holes and
equivalent term with a single variable X
if either ways fine
whatever your notion is given a context
another term you should be able to plug
the term into context and get the
context and determine the context of the
context if you see what I mean a so not
so like to give me a unity function
teacher sitio del Sigma and unary
functions unity define these are
literally definable functions in the
Finnish logic but these are these will
play a major role in what's going on
anymore so generally speaking given any
algebra a we are we can we've got the
semantics of the contest because just a
composition of functions with with a
single variable so I can define a unary
function so C sub a is unary functions
defines these are the definable unary
functions and what's more for any
content for any homomorphisms is to
preserve the operations it's going to
preserve the so defined unary functions
H of the C sub a of a is C sub B of HIV
contextual equivalence it's just that to
to semantics to are something two terms
are equivalent if not context they have
the same meaning so as to find relative
again to some plan semantics and that's
a context with several holes and if you
want to do an exercise mentally or fly
in restricted context with one hold that
is equally general okay and so that
gives this equivalence relation and a
semantics is fully abstract if and only
if having the same meaning is the same
as being equivalent in that sense these
are just the traditional definitions in
this context so let's see what kind of
little a little a standard fact is there
any adequate semantics adequate
homomorphic semantics is at least half
fully abstract this is the easy half
which we always have you prove adequacy
you get this half why is that well
suppose T and you have the same meanings
for the HTT cottage of you then any
context they're going to have the same
meaning because that see if H of C is
just C of age a there and then you're
done there
yeah I've gone to the U and that's fine
you get back out again that's right so
so the so the C of T and C if you have
the same meaning because of form or is
'm therefore they have the same
I mean according to semantics so bad you
could say that's the case so that proves
that we're under seal it the other way
around that so that's more hard okay yes
okay but can we say this
diagrammatically so so we're interested
in the meaning of something in a context
so that's saying we're interested in the
meaning of something in the function
space from context to meanings okay so
we've got a meaning M sub content we can
lift the meaning function from else L -
M - a function from L - M context by the
meaning of T in a context is a meaning
the meaning of T at a context is the
meaning of T in the context okay and we
could do something similarly here and
then there's a natural this is this
natural function here hey what does it
do it takes it takes a and in the
context you take you take you take you
apply the definable function you know a
function that this context defines and
then do the original little m here so
this this dopes this diagram commutes
and to say that is to say the previous
lemma but more more categorically a I'm
using this so anyway so any adequate so
to make construct this diagram you have
to have an adequate semantics and using
this diagram you can see what full
abstraction is fill traction says if two
things are the same in all context has
to say if they receive the same value
here then they receive the same value
there okay in particular if this happens
to be a model then that's true and
conversely if this is a surjection then
this is a model if it's fully abstract
so this is notion so seen someone at
mano work there's no stuff semantically
abstraction which I find assumptions
papers at some point so that's that's a
categorical definitely semantically full
abstraction so now we have categorical I
mean I'm only writing in sets but with
categorical ideas now for us adequacy
full abstraction semantical full
abstraction they're all quite natural in
terms of various diagrams the only good
a
but there's one thing we haven't done
algebraically we've got this equivalence
relation of being equal in all contexts
but that's doesn't sound algebraic but
in fact is a very natural notion of this
it turns out that two terms are
equivalent that this thing this a
Congress is simply the largest possible
congruence that you have an else again
which is compatible with being
equivalent semantically equivalent a so
why is that the case evidently if you're
equal in all contexts you're equal in
the empty context so you're certainly a
subset of there and suppose we've got
two terms which equivalent take any
context and so what's the meaning of C
of up of T of U well we've got as it
were of the context I don't know suppose
you make a hole just here okay then you
and you prime have the same in your
context so these two things are the same
meaning now we'll keep this u prime
fixed to make a hole just here and then
you get the other part okay and so
notice ur this argument critically
depends on the function symbols being
finite rate it'll break down if they're
infinite or e we'll see a country
example later because of that yeah and
the largest is another the Clarke event
which I think I'm gonna skip because I
can feel time slipping away
hey okay so now that's actually enough
our polymer is to give Wilfrid Hajis
construction in in one slide so a so
what we do is we just take our language
and we divide it out by this largest
congruence okay so that's the definition
here we get this thing commuting and so
that says what we've got is an adequate
model and then we can construct this
thing but then we it's easy to see that
this mixes fully abstracted suppose two
things have the same meaning here that
means no context any of the same meaning
that means that are congruent well that
means they have the same meaning there
because it goes same equivalence class
this is a surjection so it's also
semantically fully upside so that's what
that's as cheap as you can get Deana but
it's very pretty all the same so there's
absolutely no information about what
this could possibly look like but but it
exists okay so that's pretty cool it
exists in this simple
situation a it's actually good nothing
to do with whether the fact that this is
the initial algebra any of the same
construction works for any algebra so if
you think any algebra on a semantics are
covering you have the equivalence
relations before in any context we can
say two things equivalent if they're
they're equivalent under the application
of all unary definable functions and
once again we this becomes largest
congruence and we have a generalized
notion to fill abstraction okay hey now
this might be useful
a suppose for example we want to build
them in some equivalence relations into
our programming language by having some
algebraic theory like for example to
continue Prakash example semicolon is
actually associative and I'd skipped as
the identity so we might not want to
take a you might not see the theory of a
monoid so it turns out that whatever
equations this a base this e this will
base to so here you get a full
abstraction for languages with built in
or it's called yeah the similar things
happened in process on to proceeding so
you still get fully abstract full
abstraction there and so in general
given any financial mourner the finally
monad is something you kiss expertise by
function symbols or finite Araki you get
a fully abstract semantics for any
pre-algebra there so in the case when
this is monoids that Sigma is the
alphabet and this this is this the super
shape construction okay so everything
fits together that's nice and I said in
this case the one whole context of the
forum familiar from the sometimes
definition
good so feeling feeling happy
momentarily what one I won't want to do
some other example so I said you can do
multi sorter so we're going to do that
one slide I'm assuming how about 10
minutes 15 okay let me try for 10 and
feel okay so Amy so here we have a
signatures of a set of source operations
now the arguments are sorted and the
result is sorted so we go from s 1 s k 2
s po so for example like scores from two
objects to a proposition in a natural
language case a algebras you have
carriers for every sort and operation
symbols are suitable functions on the
products of the carriers Congress is
suitable farmers equivalence relations
coverings now come in families a if you
it might be the case sports suppose
you're doing a operational semantics
that you only care about a particular
category in your programming language
like arithmetic expressions and the
coloring is the value that they evaluate
to but you still require tough coverings
for all the other things but you can
just a trivial colorings that it takes
EES to be a one point set and that
doesn't that does it so Congress for
syntactic algebra is a so two elements
as a sort are wise that see they're
totally forgotten Amy they're equivalent
can't see why anyway an equivalent
attesa for every place s Prime you can
map them to in every context it goes
from s to s prime well that's the color
I'm sorry yes it should be capital A
then C at a as a coolant s prime to see
a of a so two things are congruent if
whenever you map them to anywhere they
have to have the same color okay and
then you get exactly the same diagrams
and theorems as before but it's not
worthwhile writing it all out hey so
that's good so let's do something prima
fasci a little more challenging
what's judge sousou's him princess I'm
not gonna do anything to mean theoretic
but what one can do it but just seemed
like you getting into technicalities
about topology and so forth it won't
benefit the discussion so I'm not so bad
I always do this example because it's
kind of it's nice so with the lambda
calculus or that has a binder so you
have free variables in this bound by
lambda so X is bounded em or we have
integration a this DX is a binder it
binds this X and the function symbol but
there's nothing but by a and B are not
bound by it quantifiers for all xpx SX
binds fee so these things occur all over
the place right ok can we deal with them
as well so the idea is you have a
fancier notion of signature so so what
you do is a binding signature and
operation no longer is a synch this is
so this is unary sorted but with binding
ok
there's also multi sorted with binding
but never mind a so so each argument of
the operation can now bind some
variables so those key arguments and the
eyuth argument binds bi many variables
okay so for example lambda calculus has
0 0 because it's got two arguments and
doesn't bind any variables in either a
lambda is one because it's got one
argument and binds in that argument a
integration is 0 0 1 because it has
three arguments doesn't bind those and
it does bind this one generalized
quantifiers all these things fit into
this kind of picture so we're binding
terms and we're given a sequence of a
bit of sequence of variables we can see
whether or not term M is a valid term
with three variables x1 through xn I
haven't spelt out the details of a form
system of the kind that apricot referred
to but I'll give one nasty example
because the services as well there's a
different thing so here's a button
binding term op there's going to have K
arguments and the first argument will
have B oh yeah b1 many parameters and
the K tart North became any parameters
so you write all this so is this a valid
term with these free variables well you
take a particular M and a you have to
see that it's valid one given the P
variables x1 through xn and these
additional variables you may say in the
bacteria is what happens if is a
variable collision and there's bits of
random magic you're supposed to discuss
in detail which say don't worry about it
so don't worry just pretend it can't
possibly be okay okay so what's the
notion of a binding algebra here it
turns out to be a well-known notion well
one reason ball thing to do is notion of
a clone an abstract clone around the
concrete clone so it's not a clone of
operations an abstract alone so you have
a family of sets en these are going to
be the beginning of the terms with n
free variables and you have projections
are like composition given a and as a
where a function think of as a function
an abstract function with n arguments
and n functions with M arguments you get
an emery function so you've projected so
you some accidents for projection so you
can do composition sorry okay
that is the composition but rather than
actually write comp a lot of times I
just write F I write F of G one through
G n R on writing comp or bracket F comma
G once again so forth so we have a bunch
of obvious a axioms so those of you who
know well know perfectly well so what
once sorted a multi category and it's
also a pre-shave in a suitable category
but I'm just going to this concrete
thing to work with operations but I
guess the novel point is not only that
you have a clone but you use the clone
to interpret your operations okay so
these are the operations so what so what
so what we going to suppose have caught
see the clone eventually is going to
have yeah let me go back to two here
we're going to have to interpret this
but give it an operation that might have
a I should really put a P here it can
have all these X's free in it as well so
we think of these as parameters so we
need an interpretation no matter what
our collection of parameters are sweet a
family of meanings a so what so suppose
we've got people eaters then we're good
the result of it will be a function as
it were with P arguments and say the
first thing you're going to bind b1
things so the first thing is going to
need a b1 plus p parameters and so forth
so you're gonna have a family of peas of
ups what parameterize by P of this
nature and you want these all to be
connected so you want roughly speaking
in fact compose with these parameters I
can pose some functions and then do the
off that thing is the same thing as
doing the OP and then doing the
composing this is called the uniformity
condition and that's that's here now
again comes out naturally if you do some
pretty version of this a the semantics
is given any m with prescribed ordering
of its free variables then you get a an
element of CN or just write CM you don't
bother with the details and this is an
example here you basically saying see
see if the ops is off of the seas okay
so this is compositional but it said the
right notion of compositional for this
rather nasty form of algebra a you can
define homomorphisms
and their chests exactly what you think
a family of maps from CN to DN which
preserve everything in sight and
congresses their equivalence relations
which are agree with everything inside
and
yes yeah so what I want to point out if
we go back even to the beginning to
where here it looked like we were doing
something different but in fact we've
already done this this is a particular
case for most assorted algebra right so
we could apply the feeder you already
have and so we automatically a full
abstraction that was kind of cute that I
said where it isn't very explicit
because you've got you've got all these
free variables to one hand the other
hand you've got all these numbers N and
it's very annoying you have to translate
backwards and forwards so want to show
you a little bit of the translation and
how it comes out after the translation
okay so see so here's a particular Asti
one so how do I describe the initial
algebra in terms of term in terms of
terms and variables well I wanted to say
what the watson c k CN here that's every
n so it has to be terms with n free
variables but which free variables so
you just do some standard free variable
Z 1 through Zn now we're always going to
work with terms with free variables Z 1
through Zn 4 and that means we're
constantly going to have to be renaming
all these variables and maybe I won't
and one suffers prove a way but but it's
perfectly fine and it's very annoying
one has to do the suffering and anyway
this kind of suffering occurs in many
places in category theory in algebra
okay how about full abstractions well I
don't need to see any more accelerated
they said what it is but be nice to
translate what does it say into this
kind of terah me thing and so what one
can do that yeah I'm gonna use that five
minutes a so so listen let's say context
are terms with the hole right here
here's one and this hole binds what Y is
by husbanding forcing it and accessed by
an enforcement so this context will
capture any X's and Y's okay so we
talked about when a context captures
some things and they're contextual
equivalence is as follows M and n are
equivalent if for any you take you take
any sequence of variables y1 through yn
and you take any context capturing y1
through oin it
Kenny this M is going to have three
variables x1 through XM so we take em
and for x1 you substitute p1 and all the
way through and then you get a term
whose free variables are exactly y1
through yn this context is then going to
capture it and so this will be a closed
term so I'm assuming only that we have a
meaning for the closed terms so cm is
equivalent to n if that's equivalent to
that and fully abstract model which is
just another way of writing you know you
have to do some work actually a is that
there was a binding algebra C such that
two things are equal if and only if
you're equivalent so that's another
cheap theorem but slightly less cheap
than the previous one ok might amuse you
to look at so a question is if we do
universe large but before what's
universal algebra here and so here's
some equations for logic and for lambda
calculus so he so for example ETA says
if I apply X to Y and bindin Y that's
the same as X is the untyped lambda
calculus
it was beta well if I apply I take
lambda X and apply F to X then as f of X
but it turns out this F to be Axum
enticing properly is not a variable
it's a function variable you have to
live function variables to get a proper
equation or thing okay
and equally here you see where it's
going to I'm talking about for all f of
X I need to be able to substitute in for
the this some abstraction to get general
formula that's what was on so that's
kind of cute I mean it's interesting to
us in Berkeley which one of the places
were algebraic logic got invented sees
another version of algebraic logic ok
logic is just some algebra with
quantifiers with binding symbols and you
just and eight algebra size that you
give an equation alii and it's pretty
easy I won't go through details these
are the right equations for a for all to
present the the rules of first-order
logic in this way and if you want a fun
exercise to go home with a frame this is
nothing it just is just ordinary
first-order logic
brain says it's fine see set five
Quillen to see if phi is provable if and
only if c is provable and then sure this
then
- well I shall be verified two things
are equivalent in a sense if normally if
they're provably equal it is yes yes
that's true so what that's not the point
here the point here is that this year
the equivalence relation of inter
probability is given this week there was
a little theorem to prove okay so having
so having everything being positive
I want to almost conclude with something
negative a so let's oh he's little
theorem let a be an algebra two
conferences such the least equivalence
relation containing them is not a
congruence any algebra oxidized by
finite airy operations that this
candidate opposes cannot hold the
conference they could all this later
preserve for the operations whatever
they are and wherever your notion of
Equalization is what a very notion of op
greatness okay and it's got no syntactic
algebra with respect to coloring
corresponding to that and it's an easy
proof and I'm not going to take that
it's basically you end up showing that
this equivalence relation this
congruence has to actually be this but
this can't be that can't that that
contradicts if either this isn't a
congruence but I think I'll skip the
proof and then Nikolai has this nice
country example so so the ideas think of
some sequence a naught a 1 a 1 a 2 a 2 a
3 then the 1 conference is going to make
a knot in a 1 congruent and a 2 and a 3
and then a 4 and a 5 and so forth the
other Congress is going to make a 1 and
a 2 congruent and a 3 and a 4 and so
forth so between a lot of them
everything is going to be congruent to a
0 but if you start off with it but the
number of steps that you need to take to
get to a 0 keeps increasing so this
thing although you can get any
individual argument down all the way
Canton finitely many steps yeah all the
way down and it's only finitely stepped
many steps we have available because of
the fact that we've got an equivalence
relation I just let you do one step so
these are two things which are not
equivalent but they are congruent so so
that that's pretty bad
okay so here so that that monad is not
fine a tree
so I conject your question which we
don't have an answer to see that say
that I'm Oh 19 admit syntactic algebras
if any T algebra syntactic comfortable
with debate any coloring conjecture is T
admit syntactic algebras if and only if
it's fine a tree don't know if that's
true or not because I has some
particular case of that of T's of a
certain nature then then basically being
of that nature means you can transpose
that country example to that to that
context so you get a bit more Jenna but
we don't really know so we're relying on
you to solve this one or someone someone
who's more intelligent both myself hey
okay what next well this seems quite
nice there's lots of natural questions
that come up so what things work well
for finer tree monads so how about a
enrich finance Ramona's so is it the
case that if any more enriched over a
local I finally presentable category
admit syntactic all-purpose I think it
is that should be okay
a question of suffering through
definitions but I don't actually know a
it's nice that we can do things at a
general level who seem to have done even
if only cheaply full abstraction and so
forth and adequacy a general level a
what else can we do a general level and
can come with relate things in
particular I think an interest question
was like I mean this is a connection bar
there useful connections on one side or
another between semantics of programming
language in algebraic language city for
example duality there's very important
in both and that is not a coincidence I
think as a similar thing is happening
there but they're being used for
different purposes so I think that
should be investigated and then of
course going back to Prakash in physics
what happens beyond the Cartesian case
so thanks a lot
so about the binding algebras with the
lambda signature this would correspond
so sorry I you have not stated but I
assume that adequacy and perhaps even
full obstruction results are related in
the same way identical these are
particular examples is what we use from
a multi orienting perspective what we
used to call from the lambda algebra and
then there's something called models we
also have extensionality which is not an
algebraic identity it's first order in
relation is I would you know die I do
believe that for single models for which
full instruction was shown they were
actually laptop out yeah that's a good
point
I'm gonna need to need to go back and
relay that to these previous frameworks
I haven't done that right so I mean just
just see what you're saying is a
perspective that is which you should go
week extensionality but strong
extensionality is more interesting
because that's what happens in the yeah
I'm sure you what you're seeing is right
now because you double check yeah
yes
and the other pitfall and I wonder how
it fits into your scheme to take
primitive recursive functions everyone
agrees that if you have given function
and make a primitive recursive
definition that the resulting thing is
fully defined but equations between
primitive religious functions are not
recursively enumerable so don't prove
system ever gives you all true the
qualities between primitive recursive
functions as function says all there but
isn't that a pitfall in knowing which
yes yes I mean you we know that we know
the fully abstract thing exists but it
can be absolutely horrible yeah
this particular case would be there's no
reason why it has to be re or anything
I'm still trying to connect these two
talks that's your problems to be this
notion independence so you've got
physically independent systems you can
read about them separately and then
compose them looks like the notion of
context is where you have some
interaction and that's away whatever
basics making explicit what the
interaction is if you take context into
account you can still get the degree of
compositionality yes they're saying that
you can get a cheaply because if you
just take all possible context into
account then your composition on that
but what you would like is like some
limited notion of context yes so in
particular they've been instead of then
you could take the semantics to be a set
of formulae that are true of the system
and then that won't be compositional in
general for example in operational
because the operations amount is just a
semantics and the homomorphism is a
denote an absolutely no information just
just the existence result they should be
it should cheer up those people climbing
the mountain to know there's a tall yes
for any particular example those
problems you only you don't you get
something but you know
[Applause]